blak strong and tasty that describes the
beer that I guess hungers brews for the
past 10 years he's run a small brewery
in the Latvian town of Ville Mira and
with great success booming sales are the
reward for all his hard work and
commitment I was scared to death
honestly because I had very big bank
loans I had very big investment loans
and I had no money left myself but the
idea was that we really believed in our
product in our taste or beer and we
looked for every small possible
opportunity to improve our situation
just a few years ago his company nearly
folded the 2008 global economic crisis
hit Latvia especially hard the longest
could see how bad the economy was but
the fact that his sales were down by 20%
Latvians were drinking less of his beer
his brewery would not have survived with
our support from the European Union my
strategy was keeping to the high quality
beer and one opportunity we decided to
use we started to invest in even higher
quality in him and higher quality beer
and then we started to use subsidies
from lucky and Rural Development Agency
when we investor let's say 1 million
euro we get 1/2 million in subsidies
back so it was a very good time to
invest he wants to show us where the
money went
so he takes us to his brewery on the way
he tells us that to get out of the
economic crisis Latvia adopted strict
austerity measures it cut pensions and
balanced its national budget but it also
got millions of euros from Brussels for
infrastructure his hometown of Vell Mira
built new roads squares and bridges he
doesn't understand why Greece doesn't
take advantage of these possibilities
my advice is really to use all the
opportunities or the positive
opportunities what europa offers because
there is possible to get investment that
is possible to get because good business
partners there is a Europe is a very
really very big market so really to the
use of this positive side what Europe
could offer longus is not the only one
who thinks that way many Latvians have
little understanding for Greece's
demands for ever new bailout packages
Marcus coming visit big stir I think the
Greeks were really irresponsible with
the money especially the funds they were
lent they had every opportunity and
plenty of time to get themselves out of
the crisis we here in Latvia have set a
good example of how it can be done
they've always had much higher pensions
better Social Security benefits and they
even get a 13th monthly wage we got rid
of all that here I think that sets a bad
example for all the other countries that
are struggling the message is don't pay
back your debts that would apply to
Spain Portugal and also us here in
Latvia where back hit hungers his
brewery he shows us the new brewing
copper's where he brews his beer
according to an ancient recipe that
calls for it to age for a month longer
than with other methods his brewery
produces nearly 2 million liters per
year he employs 100 people and it's
likely he'll be hiring more
I'm from Palmyra so it's great I can
work in my hometown I've been doing this
job for six years I have no reason to
leave the country in search of a better
job so the Mira is enjoying a little
employment miracle despite the financial
crisis and the sluggish economy
I guess longer says Latvia's past as a
Soviet republic as part of why it's
successful
unlike Greece the Latvians are a little
bit like cats because we always know how
to fall on the legs for last 20 years
probably Latvians our crisis
professionals so for us the next
economic crisis which was the global
crisis was just for us to get ready how
we can overcome it so we were always
like positive thinkers what we should do
to overcome it mungus ends his work day
after nearly 12 hours and of course he
does so with a glass of beer fresh from
his own brewery
like many Latvians he's very happy to be
a member of the European Union